hello i'm lauren the creator of feminist
baby
jelly bean comics and the good advice
cupcake hi i'm kira
lead animator and voice actress of the
good advice cupcake hey i'm kevin and i
don't have anything to do with a good
advice cupcake
but i'm happy to be here and today we're
going to be drawing the good advice
cupcake
in random cartoon styles how do we feel
about that very nervous
no don't you create a nice cupcake
you're going to do fine
[Music]
[Applause]
lauren you're up first spin the wheel
okay here we go
[Music]
simpson's okay all right okay
i'll take that all right kyra you're
next yes
okay ready go
tim burton oh my yeah boy
i love tim burton style that'll be so
much fun okay here we go my turn here we
go
spongebob yeah of course of course
of course like i haven't like i haven't
drawn spongebob enough
on this show you're destined to draw
more spongebob
so lauren what what's the origin story
of cuppy
how did you come up with me um copy came
from a lot of things but
mainly cuppy came from a comic and i
just like i love
cute things that are surprisingly angry
or aggressive kind of like i mean kind
of like me and kira
so i made this comic about a cupcake
getting really aggressive and it did
really well
and um our head of animation buzzfeed
was like
oh we should do an animation of this and
kyra had just come on and um
it was just like a perfect it was like a
match made in heaven are you a fan of
cupcakes is it
like i love sweets yes cupcakes and
champagne
all day every day i mean i don't drink
all day but um
if i could i probably would wouldn't we
all though
so then kyra what when you got the call
from lauren
to start working on copy like what were
you thinking
i was so excited it was like so crazy
because it was kind of like my first
official like animation job but it was
really exciting because like lauren
and just buzzfeed in general gave me so
much freedom so then yeah what's the
what's the process
uh for for coming up with like a copy
segment we kind of got it down to like a
science when we started i would do some
like rough storyboards and then kara
would forward it and then
you know we kind of do the whole process
step by step but then eventually it was
just like i could just write out like a
half-faked idea
um some dialogue and stuff and then be
like yeah can you animate this and
wouldn't have to put like any acting
notes or anything and she would just
kind of like make it happen and make it
awesome
so tell me more about that process then
so like lauren where
does i hate to do this but like where do
you get your ideas from
that's a good question and i have lots
of really weird answers for it
i love it i love a weird answer i love a
weird thing i gotta say like
you know over the years i've had to come
up with like ideas
pretty much non-stop through my career
and um i think it's sort of like
you have this tension in your mind like
i want to do
something really funny that's going to
make lots of people laugh
and be awesome and you kind of like have
that in the back your mind and then
eventually
when you're not thinking about it the
ideas start popping up and then one idea
like
makes another idea that said i just had
a baby and my brain i
my brain's like a potato now so i don't
know
do you have mommy brain now i have major
mommy brain
um do you guys remember what's the uh
what the painting behind the simpsons
couch is
because i cannot remember it it is a
boat a white
a sailboat with white sails oh okay glad
you remember that because i never would
have recalled them
really no i like i feel so ashamed i was
thinking about this last night i've
never seen a full episode of the
simpsons
what i haven't oh my god
kyra that's no you're you're out you're
out of the game kyra
we were doing the simpsons drawing one i
was like i haven't seen any episodes
and you were drawing with the simpsons
anime i know i felt horrible
hey lauren i'm here too oh my god
totally forgot cubbies here what is
happening right now
do you guys want to meet cuppy yeah oh
my god
oh my god look at this oh she came out
so good
oh cara hasn't seen her yet i know this
is like my first time seeing her
the knife oh my god it has a knife yeah
so we have a puppy plushie now and it
has keira's voice in it
oh my god kyra your voice isn't a
plushie
it's so weird it's like cesarea oh my
god okay so
is this is this something that people
can buy like right now
it goes on sale march 15th and if you
follow cuppy's instagram page
you can find the link to buy it amazing
i want one so cara i have to ask
where did the copy voice come from so
the cuppy voice like i've always kind of
had like
a bit of a higher pitch voice you don't
sing
[Music]
noticed it especially like when i talk
to animals and like oh i
know and stuff so when we needed a voice
for cuppy
i was like i could try voicing it you
just did it on a lark it wasn't
something that
that you were like specifically like i
want to be i want to be a voice actor
yeah it was literally just like this is
something that
like we need a voice for this character
so we can like post this episode
it was so like last minute sort of
thinking
i don't know i think mine's gonna look
kind of cursed
mine's definitely cursed nice i love
cursed art
so does the draw-off audience so make a
curse
how's everybody's drawing coming i don't
know how the color will go but
yeah i gotta make some color decisions
like do i go
with spongebob colors or do i stick with
copy colors i think spongebob colors i
want to see
if i want to see that okay okay this is
interesting because
now cuppy is a yellow cake cupcake
oh my goodness like what should should i
switch the frosting color too
yeah the chocolate frosting okay that's
weird
it's weird so lauren kira what is the
future for cuppy
well that is a good question we have
the plushie coming so that's the next
big thing for her
and also we're we're getting we're
turning our attention to tick tock
and we're going to try to make some
really funny tick tock videos soon
oh cool speaking of tick tock i do
follow
kira your character chicken nugget on
tick tock
oh i think and i'm a big fan
is there a cuppy chicken nugget
crossover in the works
oh my god we should do that yeah
that's a great name we haven't even why
am i the one who's suggesting this
well because that's it that's a really
good idea the chicken nugget characters
and cuppy both have food related names
right
i thought that was intentional are you
telling me that's all a mistake or just
a happy accident yes we like food
and then lauren what's next for you um
well
i have a new picture book out called
blanket i'm also working on a book for
next year
a baby book a board book called it had
to be you which is about um like the
journey
to meeting your baby however they get to
you whether it's adoption or
whatever happens it can be quite the
quite the ride that's amazing
how do we think we did kyra how do you
think you did i think i got like the
vibe of it down excellent lauren how did
you do
i think i did okay i really thought this
was gonna be like a big public
embarrassment but i don't i don't hate
it
it's cute hey that's all you can ask for
is that you don't hate it right no i
don't hate it okay let's send them to
each other
let's do it
[Music]
oh my god oh my god these are amazing
lauren you like killed it out lauren you
drew an entire scene
it's a simple scene a simple scene that
looks wow
we were right to put our money on you
and oh my god kevin
amazing i thought he was wearing or i
thought they were wearing a beanie
on cuffy's head that's until i wrapped
up some brown frosting
the fusion oh my gosh keira this is
amazing like this looks straight out of
like a tim burton
sketchbook like even even with like the
little swirls you know for the
for the cheeks and whatnot oh yeah i
love it hi
everyone it's me the goodie vice cupcake
oh jeez hi cuppy wow
look at this some beautiful art
i totally love the uh
poop hat i would
definitely wear that maybe sometimes
[Music]
doesn't seem like you like them very
much puppy
no i do they're great they're
they're interesting we tried our best
yeah cuppy we really tried our best and
you know we're supposed to be drawing
you in different styles right
you know what though you tried your best
and that's all that
matters i'm a good advice cupcake
but you are the good advice cupcake bye
cuppy thanks for stopping by
anytime i don't think cuppy liked our
drawings i don't think so either
i think she's just pretending to be nice
she's a really tough art director
thanks for joining us remember if you
want a copy plushie be sure to follow
cuppy on
all of their socials or check out the
link in the description
if you want a better look at these
drawings your drawings and to find out
when the next draw off challenge is
be sure to follow us on twitter and
instagram at drawoffshow
and we'll see you next time